[Music]
we've got one I mean decked and won cash
that's right tell me about this I should
give you a nice balance yes I needed a
balance beautiful everything had to toe
beauty thank you yeah the custom
designers of that doesn't breathe when
you're working outside in the heat does
it yeah I mean it's interesting cuz you
know we shot a bit of a colder time of
the year now is not quite as cold but
it's not the height of the summer that I
felt in and then lads over the years I
still feel like I'm in that okay time
period for this wait until next month
well it's good to see you guys and I
have to say you really got everybody
excited when you posted a shot of
directors chairs and drums what
directors know those those marching your
chair a director's chair okay yeah yeah
and who else was with it was who else
Black Widow yeah yeah all right so tell
me the significance of that shot and the
drum and everything happening
well the drum is there because sometimes
we bring drums to set and play them and
I just happen to be sitting there and
was looking across the way because
sometimes you don't sit in your own
chair and my chair was between theirs
and I was like well who put the drum
over here and I saw the picture and they
had built the river behind which is
crazy so I just wanted to get a shot of
the chairs and the river and it's a good
shot man to be condon yeah yeah and
you've worked with these guys before how
is it different on an avenger set versus
black panther set it's it's um you know
there's a there's a certain amount of
comfort I think with the Avengers
because it's been done before you know
although this is a different version of
it there's some new challenges you know
we're all comfortable with each other
and
we have a lot of fun not that not that
we didn't have fun on the Black Panther
said but it was it was a new thing you
know yeah it's a little concept and you
don't quite know what it is what it
supposed to look like what it supposed
to sound like I feel like so it's a lot
more pressure and angst on the Black
Panther say from what they but the the
culture I think I was trying to bring
you talk about the drums some of that
culture that we had and freeness of
spirit on to this set which is which has
been good so you you guys do you bring
some music in between takes or when you
guys especially especially especially
you know on that black panther said we
did but but only a couple of days here
okay
yeah you need to bring incorporate it
more I think you know sometimes of you
if you're wearing the suit you don't
have time okay you can't exactly play
the drums with the suit on
well how did you welcome deny into this
part of the marble you know it's who
into Avengers I'm not quite sure how did
it but I just I felt like we it wasn't
just me I think everybody there Chris
Scarlett everybody there Maggie Mae had
ever had a Maki welcome you these are
priceless okay the kids are still awake
like see everybody out there I hadn't
met everyone before so it was very it
was awesome and he you know he instantly
you know there's such a brother-sister
leanness between us so you know seeing
him was like you know different set you
know I mean
and then meeting everybody they were
very very very welcome well Scarlett
said she was so pumped to have you to
have you know brie Larson like more
females in this world now so you guys
are providing a little bit of balance
with all that testosterone right you
know I I think that a little bit is more
than right yeah yeah I come in like it's
not just me I come in with an arm she
has an army who look just like me yeah
we're all like this you know and so it
is kind of an injection of a different
type of energy I imagine but like yeah I
mean honestly it felt like it felt very
congruent it felt very like there was no
space for us in the world that was
really kind of cool and and the scene
that we the wakanda's scene that we shot
we really brought know what kind of
culture to to the moment and that that
was experienced wonderfully by everybody
everyone really kind of enjoyed it
oh wow this is you know what what Conda
in the house yeah oh yeah bring it in
strong with the drawing with the sounds
and the we our language you know we had
just finished shooting our movie so it
was almost like we just walked right
into this one so yeah that that feeling
like it almost felt like I didn't have
to welcome you because it's like we was
still shooting the same well when you
think about this particular movie it is
the scale is massive I think there are
64 characters from the Marvel Universe
here how many can you guys name in 30
seconds can you rather I'm not even
gonna try No
what was more difficult training for the
Marvel Universe or training for The
Walking Dead ah it's so interesting I
mean it really was they were both very
new to me it was interesting because you
know their work certain forms that do
parallel between you know training with
the katana and training with the staff
but at the same time they're they're
very significantly different there were
times I would like my staff I would be
trying to like I'd do like a finger like
oh yeah stuff still do that that's
swords do that you know so I had to
reprogram in a lot of ways and it's
still as both of them are their learning
curves they continue there's never time
I'm like yeah I'm good I got this what
did your training kind of help prepare
you for this in a way in a way in a way
in some ways I really felt like I was
training a new when I came here and then
in some ways there were there were
things like I could totally borrow from
but yeah there it was it was a beautiful
different style I think you know
Michonne she's uh she's very economical
and you know an efficient and very
specific with her with her work whereas
Akoya she's coming from a place of a
degree of certain degree of style and
it's almost like there's so much
tradition in what she's doing so she's
her approach is very like by the
traditional book in terms of how she's
approaching how she moves so they were
they they but largely they felt like I
was learning a new boat I'm very
different well who goes hardest in the
gym well Chad comes with us she does
know was I was just about to say she was
like you go yeah she worked so hard in
in getting a Koei's styling and her
weaponry so it was a joy to watch that
but Peter goes hard too oh yeah
Peter makes a lot of noise what's the
regimen in the gym what's your yeah the
physical regimen chad comes with folks
you know saying check the drum would
make god that drummer helped us we you
know when Jabbar in the plan
and you're trying to get these moves
down and sorry hitting them drums and
we're like okay turn off the hip-hop
we got like some drum in the house and
literally it would help me so much to
find firstly this African woman in me
and also to find the rhythm of how she
would move with her weapon that was
traditional to her people so you know
Chad came with some support systems that
helped us all I wanted I wanted to make
sure that that the movement was was not
just Asian martial arts a lot of times
you see that that you could see the
African influence and the martial arts
they can be Asian but but there are
African martial arts as well and you see
them in dance and you see them hidden
inside inside our culture so you know I
wanted to make sure that was there so I
I brought a few people along with me who
did you bring to make it authentic
Jabari excellent who was a drummer also
hip-hop artists Maurice Crump
Addison Henderson and they would this
this what am i my group of people that
that uh they help me in terms of the
character and movement and helped
everyone that week this week that
basically would say tweak this yes
that's that's more so forth the stunt
coordinators who also brought their own
elements to to it as well but when she's
saying I brought our bar people she's
referring yeah for the press so they
were part of my my prep prior to coming
and also during during the time we were
here so it's it's everything from you
know Donbas boxing Capra where it's
hairy mouth so just boxing in general
Aikido jujitsu some weaponry so yeah
it's is you know weightlifting all of
that so what you're saying is you can
kick somebody's butt after all with the
training
well the crossover in this film is I
mean it's remarkable you've got
guardians of the galaxy you've got Black
Panther you've got Captain Marvel with
the Avengers
like how cool has that been to be a part
of this as well and and do you guys ever
think like Oh like I'm kind of geeking
out like like there's Iron Man there you
know we're working with you know yeah no
that's I think every one of those films
have a different rhythm a different you
know a different style and you watch
those movies like I remember seeing a
mannequin like I've never seen a more of
a movie like this and you know you you
sort of you sort of want your movie to
be as good but then it's got to be its
own thing so you get to be a part of
that energy that you went to the
theaters and watched and you know but a
but a box of popcorn and enjoy now
you're part of it so it's good to to
have your own thing and bring that to
those those movies as well it's like a
separate he worked out a little when I
was like standing with them all I'm
sorry that's what I came up to you was
like was it like a big group well yeah
it was a senior shooting where we were
just kind of all standing next to each
other and I just know it way down here
and down here us you know from what kind
of you know with the different world the
different worlds colliding it's yeah I'm
the coolness of them coming to to our
world you know what I mean like you know
and this is something so cool about
about the Avengers coming to Africa
going to what Condon you know and it's
going to contain it's there are two
different movies that are being filmed
back-to-back here so it's you know it's
a long term process mm-hmm Panther we
hope to write in yeah yeah what can you
tell us thank I don't know what I can
tell you asking
either you tell no I mean I think I
think you'll the one thing you get to
see in Black Panther and in this movie
that you didn't get to see in civil ways
it introduces in an organic way the
technology in the mystery of the country
so that is all part of infinity Wars
like using it to to the advantage of the
Avengers and guardians in so I think
that's that's what you'll see for sure
yeah now when you posted that picture I
was a little surprised because Marvel
typically locks it down but you're able
to you were able to get something out
did you go rogue and do that or did you
get permission to do that I definitely
get from this you did you did okay okay
all right you didn't want to ruffle any
feathers when yeah yeah like my job have
you guys had family visit the set have
you had mm-hmm yeah uh they you know it
was funny cuz I thought they were you
know I didn't think they would have the
attention span for being here for long
cuz you know sitting on a set for a long
period of time you get tired but they
were right there the whole time so they
loved it they loved it so I want them to
come back at some point they might not
make it and during this one but probably
the next one the next one how about you
I haven't done yet I'm one of those
people like I'm at work and I'm like I'm
at work guys
work yeah you have to cut you light in a
lot you know yeah but I I do want to
stop being like that like I want to open
up like all my family does I'm away for
long periods of time doing long hours of
something you don't see the resolve but
it would be nice to have them to share
my world with them but it is hard to
kind of you know if you're at work
you're at work and that's a different
kind of vibe it is
you know but I want to be more like
others and bring family be your normal
thing to do you do your thing you do you
well so what do you guys want people to
take away when they see this movie and
they see the cultural aspects that
you're bringing in the authenticity that
you're bringing you know mmm
III think you know there's always
something you can learn from these
movies are obviously there fictitious
characters but you know the these
characters put will put aside their
differences you know that it's for the
greater good you know so that so that
they can win so that people can live and
have better lives and it's kind of like
what we need to do in in real life so if
they can take that away you know beyond
all the stuff blowing up and you know
all of the the tricks and abilities I
think that's the most important thing is
that people put aside their differences
that's how we left civil wars that
differences were not put aside so you
come into this movie having to deal with
that that weakness that's there that the
division creates the opportunity for
your enemies to come in sneak in and and
take over so you know we're dealing with
that yeah I think what you said it you
said it really the cultural components
and the authenticity and to me that's so
important I'm some iams Americans and
Bobble in an American but I grew up on
the continent and so to just to be a
part of the storytelling and to bring
this though it is a fictitious place I
mean it brings in so many beautiful
truths and I think telling the story the
way we got to tell it during Black
Panther and bringing it to this is to me
is just so kind of an answer like deep
desire I've always had which is to see
the continent portrayed and the sort of
a platform and so it is really exciting
as you know we speak close that's a
language from southern Africa that we
speak in the movie and
and you know was from civil war in fact
when you first heard it but it really is
like we've had we've embodied a culture
that that's real and and and then
brought it to to these characters into
the world that we bring and that to me
to put that on the scale that Marvel
puts things on is thrilling it's
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]